hello
大家好歡迎來到周慕姿放心說
我是周慕姿心理師
今天我們邀請的大來賓是許哲珮
hello大家好
我是Peggy
Peggy最近哦 出了新專輯
這一張新專輯
其實感覺跟我的專業很有關係
是就是叫做《樹洞裡可以悲傷》
對我那時候在聽這張專輯的時候
因為之前認識你其實是蠻早的專輯
就是那個《氣球》那張
對
應該蠻多人認識你都是因為那一張
就發現這一次的整個風格
還有
包含你寫歌詞裡面的一些一些內容
然後還有一些唱法
其實都跟以前不太一樣
不太一樣
不知道是不是我的錯覺
是 有不太一樣
哈哈哈然後因為我在聽的時候
我覺得蠻有趣的地方是
有一些歌甚至是
蠻偏向就是以前有些地方
你可能會轉換真假音啊
然後這次有一些歌
你就直接是真音給它衝上去
對對對
然後我覺得很有趣
就我想說
這個唱法
一定跟你想要就是做一些表現有關
對我覺得真的太有趣
所以我們等一下可以來聊聊這個部分
然後我這一次啊
就是邀請到折佩
我想要先
畢竟就是最近就是出了新專輯
是然後再加上這個專輯的名字
主題對
內容裡面包含有幾首歌
像是《與世隔絕的怪物》
然後黑洞
對還有就是樹洞裡可以悲傷等等
就是我覺得
很有打中我們現代人的一些心情
我在聽的時候
對我在聽的時候也很有感覺
對
我想要先問問你在做這張專輯的時候
你就是起心動念跟你想要傳達的東西
我覺得我這張專輯
是跟我過往做專輯的歷程特別不一樣
是我過去都是
我很知道我這張專輯想做什麼
不管是樂風上面的主題
或是概念上面的主題
可是來到最近這張專輯
當我覺得我要做一張專輯的時候
我突然不曉得我該做什麼
那這個感覺對我來說是很陌生的
因為我一直都是知道自己想要做什麼的
所以在這個陌生之下
你開始重新探索的過程中
我覺得我有掉入自己的黑洞
就是進到了一種
自我糾結跟懷疑的狀態
所以當我當下不曉得該寫什麼主題的時候
我覺得是我的本能
讓我去寫一些我現在心裡面的感受
所以這張專輯是
我完全就是邊走邊看
我完全沒有辦法設定它
我也不曉得他最終在講的是安放
悲傷或是療癒
我只知道我就先唱吧
所以這張專輯
就是一首一首
跟著我生命當下所經歷的過程
一首一首長出來的
哇
所以這一個創作過程跟之前很不一樣
很不一樣
那在那個過程如果很不一樣的話
我在想像就是
比如說
我們很清楚我們要做什麼東西的時候
那其實也有做的痛苦
甚至會覺得要把它生出來
然後完美主義會一直跑出來
可是我覺得不知道自己要做什麼
一邊做一邊摸索
某方面來說其實蠻可怕的
對 尤其是之前已經做了這麼多
然後這麼有控制感
然後現在完全沒有
當你做一件事情做久了
雖然你變得更專業
可是其實我們的包袱也更重
你不管是別人對你的期待
或是你自己跟你自己
上一張你會覺得我有沒有突破
我有沒有創新
其實有很多很多
已經不像我們
一開始做音樂或創作那麼純粹的事情
的時候我覺得
有時候的確會讓創作者想太多
的時候我們的腦袋真的會打結
那個打結
他就會觸動到你內在某些不安全感
所以我覺得是那個不安全感
讓我掉入了自己一種很糾結的狀況
嗯
哲珮是一個很需要控制感的人嗎
就是你會很需要
很多事情是有計劃的啊
然後在你可以控制的範圍
完全相反的
哦真的
那你之前的專輯都沒有辦法這樣啊
我我應該是說我的直覺是很強烈的
我知道我想要做什麼
可是對於計劃規劃這件事情
像我是一個
我超級不愛看說明書
所以買回來任何東西我都不看說明書
所以別人問我說啊你10年的規劃
我就是覺得這太久了
完全懂
哈哈哈所以我我不是一個會規劃的人
我都是當下感覺的人
可是當我那個當下感覺
沒有強烈到像我過往
知道我這張就要做
比如說我之前做三拍概念專輯
或是電氣搖擺
就是這麼明確的時候
我其實是有點慌的
我會覺得我的直覺
或者是我的超能力是不是不見了
我覺得是那個讓我覺得很恐懼
我覺得你這樣說起來你是p人吧
哈哈哈
我是
因為我是
我覺得這很有趣
就是我覺得有很多p人的習慣
就是很跟著直覺走
然後那個直覺
常常會帶領他們到一個很美的地方
對或是沒有辦法想像的地方
對
因為我也是p人
但是話說回來
當我發現那個平常很強烈
就是我就是知道就是這條路
我講不出理由但是就是這條路
結果這一次往那個方向走的時候
前面你不知道去哪裡
對沒有燈
對很可怕
然後要自己掌燈
是對那個可怕感覺你怎麼面對
因為我相信
有很多人也是會有經過類似的心情
你是怎麼去面對這個感覺
我覺得其實處在當下的人呢
任何的安慰跟鼓勵其實都沒有幫助
哈哈哈
所以千萬不要跟說
哲珮你一定寫的出來的
對一定會很棒的
然後加油
就想說我我我還要加哪裡的油
已經夠加油了
對就是我覺得
當下你墜入那個黑洞狀態的時候
其實我們當下最需要
就是其他人給予空間
跟理解就是我
理解你現在在一個自己的黑洞狀態
所以有沒有這樣的溫柔是
不要逼著你趕快好起來
我覺得當下
至少當下的我
我覺得那是所有人跟我說加油
我都覺得我沒辦法了
你會覺你會覺得你沒有力氣站起來
可是你也知道自己需要時間
你需要自己的時
所以呃
我覺得我慶幸的是
我還有這樣的時間
讓我在黑洞裡面找到光
然後長出樹洞
可是這一切其實別人幫不了你的
對哇
你講的好深刻
就是那種感覺
很像是在你遇到一個
你已經很想要站起來是
可是你知道你站不起來
對
然後那個無力感其實很強
沒錯
然後旁邊的人就
就他之前對你的認識
他會覺得你一定可以克服的啊
這沒有問題的
或者他要幫你想辦法 對對對
但是你知道這個無力感
其實它真的很難
它真的很難
嗯而且他說不定是我們很少遇到
或者是常常遇到的感受
但是這個困境
卻是我們現在沒有遇過的
對
對所以我覺得那感受真的是真的
是真的很像自己
就在一個洞裡面
它真的就是黑洞
它真的就是
好像你進入了一個內在的低谷那
但是我覺得換過一個方式來想
因為我現在有了孩子
所以其實我的內在低谷也只能到一個程度
因為每天固定時間
你就要接小孩放學啊
所以也是因為我的現實生活拉著我
讓我沒有真的全部掉下去
好像很有道理
對
因為如果是那個那個慘淡少年的時候
對啊如果以前我就是一個人的
時候
我應該就會回到我寫《瘋子》的狀態
我懂我懂
對
那可是因為現在你有其他的責任嗎
你有一個知道你該繼續往前進的
我覺得他也不是動力
就是你你知道你必須做這件事
他像呼吸一樣
你還有別的身份跟角色
你還是女兒啊
對吧我還是爸爸媽媽的女兒
然後我現在有了孩子
我也是他們的媽媽
所以你知道
無論你進入了怎麼樣的黑洞
你的現實生活
其實他都會在某種程度的撐住你了
嗯我覺得那個進入黑洞的狀態
他最困難的時刻
就是要維持一般正常的生活
是所以會有很多人會覺得
我已經掉進黑洞了
你還希望我維持日常的正常生活
這件事情有些人會覺得很生氣
比如說因為如果去看醫生啊
或者是找心理師啊
都會盡量鼓勵你維持生活的功能
那什麼叫做生活的功能
對對對對對
然後大家就開始生氣
我現在連活下去都沒辦法
我都覺得我掉進洞裡面
你為什麼還要我維持
但是我覺得哲珮你剛剛說的東西
真的是非常非常的深刻
嗯
就是有的時候要撐著繼續維持生活
該做的事
包含要把自己洗乾淨
對
包含要吃飯要睡覺
其實有時候要做到這件事都很困難
對但是如果我們有辦法
讓自己儘可能還做的到這件事
生活就不至於失去到我們
完全就是掉進黑洞
完全出不來
因為我覺得很有趣的是
有的時候你為了自己做不到
可是你為了你身邊愛的人
你做得到
你講的
真好我覺得這很關鍵
就是我可以放棄我自己
可是如果我身邊有很愛的人
我好像為了你
我想要再努力一點
嗯所以我覺得去找到你
你所能投射或所給予的那個物件
或者是嗜好也好
我覺得那個都是一個
我們讓自己的好起來的時間
再加速再穩定一點點的關鍵
嗯
我覺得你剛說的東西超級超級深刻
因為之前有聽過
就是哲珮你有去考催眠師的執照
然後因為你也是創作者是
然後其實你出第一張專輯的時候
就非常非常的非常有名
就是就造成市場上的一波震動
然後我我就在好奇
當你每因為身為一個創作者
每一次做東西
大家你也是一個對自己要求很高的人
每次做東西都會有那種我好像要突破
要突破
對
突破市場也好
突破銷售也好
突破自己也好
會有很多的突破
對你來說你最在意的是什麼
然後在面對這些突破的時候
你覺得最困難
會跟自己打架部分是什麼
我覺得最困難的部分應該是說
我每一次都覺得
我做不到我上一次那麼好
哦這是每一個開始
你都會覺得
我上一次已經做的太完整了
那我這次要再說什麼呢
那大家對我的期待放在哪裡
他們對我的期待
是我接下來想做的事情嗎
我覺得這個很關鍵
就是你也知道
我們都想要跟著自己的感受去做
可是實際上
你的音樂還是希望有人聽的
你還是希望大家能夠接觸到你的
所以我覺得在這中間要找到一個平衡
對我這樣的創作者來講
真的是比較困難
所以每一次我都會覺得
我做不了比我上次更好
可是每一次
我都還是可以突破當下的自己
所以我覺得
那都是我們自己內在的一個害怕吧
就是一件新的事情開始的時候
那這件事情最有趣的是在過程
無論你覺得多痛苦
你越痛苦
你做完成之後你的成就感卻又越深刻
然後當你這個作品完成了以後
你會有滿心的熱忱
覺得我還要再下一次
雖然在過程中你可能會經歷一些痛苦
對那簡直就是一個腦內飛大爆炸
就很像坐雲霄飛車
就好恐怖好恐怖好恐怖
還想玩還想玩
好舒服好舒服
對對對
然後再來一次
這樣子
我覺得好像在舞臺前的就是創作者
很多人都會有類似的感受
是對
那我剛剛在聽哲珮你說那個
就是好像會覺得自己上一次做的東西
好像已經非常完整了
這一次覺得
就是
好像很難再比上次更好的那種感覺
我就有點好奇
哲珮你覺得你是一個
雖然我剛開玩笑說
我覺得你可能是個完美主義者
但是你覺得你是個完美主義者
我應該可以說我自己在做音樂上面
我可能有一點細節控
可是我不覺得那個是完美主義啊
你知道
每一個完美主義的人都會這麼說呢
哈哈哈就是大家都會說嗯
我不覺得我是完美主義
我只是對於有一些
就是細節對比較在意
應該說我覺得的完美
不一定是
比如說其他製作人覺得的完美
或者是市場上
覺得的完美
就是每個人心裡都有一個
他對完美的定義
是像我這張專輯裡面某一首歌的完美
他就是在於他不完美
哪一首歌呢
我所珍愛的這首歌
是我的共同製作人王希文
他幫我編曲的
那希文在編曲的時候呢
他就先自己彈了一個很rap的彈
彈完了以後他就跟我說欸
Peggy到時候我們就進錄音室
我們可以試不一樣的Miking啊
跟Tone 我說不要
我就要你這個rough的吉他
因為我覺得那個情感是
是他再怎麼樣複製都到達不了的
當你因為我們都是做音樂的人
我都知道
當我很正式要唱要做要錄音的時候
我會變得很細節或是吹毛求疵
他有時候那個情感的東西
他不像demo那麼完美
還要雕塑一下
對所以其實我有很多的專輯的錄音
最後都是用我demo唱的啊
對因為我
我特別知道
那個最原始的那個是什麼
所以對希文來說
他可能覺得他那個吉他不是完美
或者在市場上他覺得哦
他那個音質怎麼樣
可是在我的感受
那個就是當下最完美的
我聽你這樣講我覺得很有趣
是因為
我反而在聽你比較早期的專輯的時候
我覺得那個很接近
就是流行音樂
然後雕塑的很完美
每個東西都編排的很清楚
很乾淨嗎
該怎麼講
就是好像都弄好了
都塞好了的那個感覺比較強
可是我反而後面你的幾張專輯
我比較感覺比較多
像你剛剛說的那個
是很像就在旁邊唱給
我聽很像
我在看live
是因為你看我們一開始進入這個產業
你知道創作是你好像本來就會的
可是其餘的你要怎麼樣精進自己
就是專業跟技術的累積
所以我的確有在前面幾年
我覺得在技術上面
我一直在學習
一直想要什麼樣的技術
才叫做最適合或最好的
那我覺得一路在學習中
當我的技術真的都已經夠了以後
我發現我可以減法了
是那個前提是
因為我都知道這些怎麼去
所以我知道我可以怎麼樣
用情感的地方去做到那樣的不
不用靠技術去做到那樣的狀態
很像返璞歸真的感覺
是但我覺得他就是一個歷程
而且我覺得那個感動度很高
我在聽這張專輯的時候
我覺得感動度非常高
是但是
所以我我那時候就一直不是很懂
為什麼我會有這種感覺
你這麼說明
我就覺得啊
好像可以理解那些東西在裡面
就是像你剛剛說的
你既要考慮市場不能不考慮
又要考慮大家喜不喜歡聽
聽了能不能療癒
大家能不能舒服
又要想我想要表達的東西
還包含你想要表達的樂風
你想要嘗試的一些
音樂的一些一些技巧啊
在這一些時候
你覺得從以前到現在
你的選擇有變動嗎
我覺得應該是說
我是一個技術性比較難被說服的人
比如說你如果跟我說這首
這張專輯請你考量市場做
我覺得我做不到
嗯對
但是如果你跟我說你這張專輯
請你回到你最初寫歌的狀態
我覺得我可
能可以啊
對我覺得我
我是一個需要用情緒語言溝通的人
所以我覺得我也特別
在溝通的過程
我很容易察覺跟讀到對方的情緒
是對
所以這無論是身為創作者或是療癒師
我覺得他可能都是某一種本能吧
沒錯因為你剛剛有講到說
你好像也會了解大家的期待是什麼
只是還要回過頭來去思考
我想要的東西是什麼
是可是我發現啊
在我工作的時候
會遇到很多人
很容易去讀別人的情緒
跟讀別人期待的人
他其實有時候會忘記自己要的東西
嗯
你是原本就做的到拉回自己想要的
還是你也是花了一段時間
才開始學會做到這件事
應該說
我一直都是太知道我自己要的是什麼
所以我反而是需要更多的感受
或者是更多的體驗
去從不同的角度去理解大家
聽到我音樂的感受是什麼
因為對我來講
音樂它就是一切
都是我的直覺
它沒有什麼我設計好的東西
它並不是以計劃為導向的
他都是我當下有一個極大的熱忱
我想要做一個這樣的主題
所以其實
我從過去
都一直都是以我自己為出發點
只是過去的我我喜歡寫故事
所以當別人覺得
你可不可以唱我的心情
可是我還是覺得
可是我想要創造別的故事宇宙
只是來到了這一次
我覺得我的確是腦中有另外一個聲音
告訴我如果你寫歌給自己會怎麼樣
哇哦對
那是完全是這個開關
讓我這張專輯的開始變得不太一樣
我覺得這個部分聽起來很讚
因為我突然很想要問你
關於催眠師的那個身份
因為當你自己可以站到前面
讓大家看的時候
那其實也要很大的勇氣
是
所以這件事情
還有跟你
就是後來就是去考催眠師證照
對這方面療癒啊等等
開始去參與或是去學習這個部分
是怎麼樣的心境轉折
讓你開始對這個部分有興趣
啊其實
我本來就是
一直對神秘學非常有興趣的
那就一直對於催眠是非常好奇的
那在十幾年前
當然就是有朋友介紹
真的去體驗了一次催眠
我自己覺得那一次的催眠體驗
有點顛覆我的人生 哇
因為他
因為我覺得
催眠其實是一種很深很深的自我探索
當然我們講前世今生
大家覺得很有興趣
可是無論你看到什麼樣的前世
他的重點都還是跟你今生有什麼關係
對不是隻是看完一個一個故事
那我看到了我的幾個前世
然後看到了我當下正在經歷的
我覺得很困難的事情
之後呢你突然有很多感受
你豁然開朗
有一些你在糾結的事情
你不再糾結了
當然我覺得催眠你的體感
你所看到那些東西太天馬行空
它本來就是很幫助創作人去延伸
發想創作
所以我自己催眠完那個體驗
那個太滿了
我太需要分享
那當我分享的時候
因為我身邊都是藝術家跟創作人
大家都很有興趣
我就很希望他們也可以體驗看看
可是大家對於催眠都有點害怕
覺得就像我們看電影嘛
就是我會把我的銀行密碼講出去
這樣子對那所以後來我就去學了
嗯我其實最主
一開始
我只是希望我幫我的朋友們催眠
是我想要讓他們也看到
我感覺到那麼神奇的世界這樣
結果是在這個過程中我才發現
催眠它除了很神奇之外
它的主軸真的還是療癒
它可以療癒到很深很深的部分
這件事情是我在開始之前
其實我並沒有預設也沒有想到的
我也沒有想過我會成為一個療癒師
嗯可是的確是在這個過程中
我慢慢理解這個療癒
可以帶給我 甚至對方的影響或者是幫助
那這件事對我就很有意義
我剛聽你在講催眠
那一段體驗我非常非常的有興趣
因為我我雖然是學心理智商相關的
但是
我們其實沒有碰這麼多神秘學的東西
然後催眠其實也有一派心理學派
但是因為我們在臺灣
我沒有去學這個東西
所以我對這個東西一直都很有興趣
然後所以我很好奇
那個時候你我不知道能不能說
你可以考慮你自己的狀態
就是
那時候你覺得你遇到的困境是什麼
然後催眠你看到了什麼
他給你的體悟是什麼
讓你有就是那麼經典的經驗
你你覺得你可以分享嗎
應該說我那個時候其實催眠
比如說像現在有個人來找我催眠
我也都會先詢問他
有沒有特別想知道的主題
那你多分享就是給我更多的線索
當我遇到的時候
我知道我們在這裡停留
所以當時催眠師也
問我說你
你有沒有什麼想知道的時候
其實我也想了很久
因為其實我當下只是對催眠好奇
我並沒有真的一個人生很大的事情
可是你隱隱約約知道
好像有些什麼
可是你整理不出來
但是的確在催眠的過程中
我發現我自己所害怕的是
我很害怕長大
對 我很害怕身份的轉變
然後長大會不會讓我變得不像自己
我覺得我發現我害怕是那一點
變成不想要成為的大人
對
可能是那在我看到了幾個前世當中
我大概也理解我
比如說我性格中的浪漫是哪裡來的
我的天馬行空是哪裡來的
甚至我在我的其中一世
我就看到我曾經就是一個女巫
所以我在那一世
我覺得我是很具體的
把我的療癒能力帶回來
那我覺得這個就非常有趣
因為以前我們做音樂
大家都說哦
你的音樂好療癒
可是其實我沒有意識我在做療癒啊
我只是在做音樂
可是
自從我把我的療癒能量拿回來之後
我覺得我開始有意識的在療癒
我覺得這是很不一樣的點
對
我發現一件很有趣的事情
因為你剛剛在講說很害怕長大
其實我們在接觸很多藝術家
創作者的時候
都會遇到這個狀況
就是所謂的永恆少女跟永恆少年
對然後這樣子
包在一個永恆少年
跟永恆少女的狀態的時候
創作的活力跟直覺力是最強的
是可以想像的事情
然後不要被外在世界困住的事情
其實越多的是
但是常常會聽到有一些人
他說他
在跟永恆少女或永恆少年交往
或是要建立關係
或是他們要進入
一般就是routine的工作的時候
大家就會開開始看到他們
開始會鬧跑
對對對因為我這種俗物
不要來煩我
就是這是一個很正常的狀態
因為就是有一好沒兩好
是對可是你剛剛在講的
就是那個轉換的過程
我想要繼續保有那一個創作力
那個活力很像孩童
是
可是我要怎麼樣
重新跟這個世界有連線
就像你剛剛說比較落地
嗯
我我那時候我剛剛一開始我們在聊嘛
對我就說這張專輯
然後你就跟我說比較落地
對那我那時候
剛剛我沒有catch到這個概念
我想說嗯
但是我聽那個風格
可能是我從芬蘭看回來
我想說這個風格感覺有點碧玉感呢
因為可能是在我程度的落底
在別人的創作程度還是很飄
沒有沒有沒有我覺我覺得
但是我覺得你說到因為
如果是用因為創作
不是隻有音樂本身表示
整個包含歌詞唱腔整個表現
我就大概懂你說落地的部分是什麼
對包含
就是我們剛剛前面讓我覺得與世隔絕
怪物你的那個唱腔
加上歌曲本身
我蠻有感的耶
我那時候聽的時候我就覺得哇
這個唱腔配這個歌真的就是很適合
然後聽著你內在吶喊
對對對
然後你那個吶喊又很節制
就很像你
是然後我就想說
哇塞好酷哦
所以這個落地就是說像你剛剛講的
就是你重新怎麼樣用你本身有的才華
才能既可以保有又可以重新
跟這個世界連線
是靠或多或少是靠催眠的這個體驗
幫你開啟這一塊
應該說呃
理解催眠的潛意識通道
以及我自己是催眠師這件事情
我非常懂得自我察覺跟自我對話啊
對我覺得這件事情
的確在過程中幫助我很多
因為在催眠
不管我們回到前世
或是回溯你今生
我們非常常用的一個方式
就是時空跳躍
我們去看十年後
10年前
所以這個路徑對我來講非常的熟悉
甚至我完全有感覺
當我需要的時候
我的過去跟我的未來
都會像金剛合體一樣來到我身邊
給我能量
這個對我來講是超級具體的
所以當我困住的時候
其實我想的是
10年前的我會對我說什麼
以及10年後的我會對我說什麼
然後當他們跟我說話的同時
我覺得我就沒有那麼害怕了
所以你剛剛在說的是
這一個催眠帶給你那些跟自我對話
對自我覺察的能力是
然後它讓你可以敢從你自己身上
重新得到力量
對然後你可以再相信你自己
對就是自我療愈
好讚哦各位朋友
所以我一直講說大家要自我對話
我真的不是隨便講講真的就很需要
哎對
但是我理解這個對大部分的人來講
真的是很抽象
真的這是什麼叫做自我對話
對對
那我可以教大家簡單的練習好了
比如說呃
你不知道過去你要講什麼
未來的你要講什麼
那你想一想
現在的你要跟過去的你講什麼
現在的你想跟未來的你講什麼
我們可以先從這個練習
因為他好像比較聚焦嘛
就是現在
那你再想一想
如果我是跟10年前的自己這麼說
那你想一想10年前你的性格
他會怎麼回答你
嗯我覺得從那過程中
好像可以稍微先練習一下
就是自我對話
因為同一個問題
我們十年之後可能會有不一樣的答案
這樣子沒錯
哲沛在說的這個方法
其實就是一個
我們怎麼樣可以慢慢的去培養
跟自己的關係
我覺得自我懷疑會發生
常常是在我們對於自我的能力不信任
跟外在的考驗太大
那有些人
是很容易對自我的能力不信任
嗯有些人是
他的外在考驗
永遠都比他現在信任自己的能力
還要大很多
是比如說創作者就是這樣
因為市場一直在變
然後自己一直在變
環境一直在變
大眾一直在變
沒錯所以不確定的東西太多
我們就會很容易自我懷疑
對可是那個要找回自我信任的能力
其實有很大一個部分真的是有辦法
我跟自己的關係比較好
是我才有辦法信任他
對我才會相信他會陪伴我
我不是孤單的
我不是一個人去面對這個困境
對但我覺得那跟性格也有關
像我覺得對我來講
我自己給我自己力量這件事情
我覺得我是做的到的
因為我都常說
我是那種靠一秒鐘的信念
就可以撐起我整個世界的那種人
讚欸
我覺得我是那種
可是我那個信念
就是隻有我自己能給我
你怎麼做到這件事
是天生個性還是你有
我覺得這個有點天生
就是我比較
我覺得我不知道大家有沒有看過
那個葬送的芙莉蓮啊
很多人應該很熟悉
對他是一個很法力很強的
就是精靈嘛
然後他有說過一句話
我非常認同
他說什麼是魔法
魔法是你只要你能想像到的事情
你能想得到
你才做得到
嗯所以我也覺得
其實我的人生就是這樣的
我我覺得我做不到我想不到的事情
可是我想得到的事情
我覺得我可以往那邊去
你可以投射的那個信念跟能量
是很強大的
那也幸好我是創作者
所以我覺得我擁有很多的想象力
他真的是我的超能力
但但是至於我在想像或者能量世界
我覺得我很強大
可是有時候回到現實世界
我覺得我很廢
就是你會覺得哇
這個是這個現實世界在運作的方式
其實有很多是我覺得我很難理解的
反而對我來講很困難的
那我覺得我幸運的是
我覺得有理解我的伴侶
有理解我的家人
他們看到了我的特點
他們沒有逼著我你要趕快長大
或者是你一定要負責這些
但是當然我懂旁邊人有時候會著急
所以在那個他們的著急也是因為愛吧
所以你會
所以我才說
很多事情你為了你自己做不到
可是你為了愛你的人
你可能可以做到
所以在他們著急的時候
但是那個時候
你還需要一點時間的時候
你會怎麼辦
你會怎麼跟他們說
我其實就是一個講情緒的人
我其實都會講的蠻清楚的
就是我其實我聽的
我知道你的意思
可是我需要時間
所以
其實你是有把你的狀態跟他們說的
對我覺得是你
你唯有說了你才可以解釋
你自己嘛
才不會說哦
你只是在賴皮
你只是在任性
可是我們真的不是
我們真的有一些經歷者
我們也正在理解的
但是當你在解釋的時候
你也一邊在梳理你自己到底為什麼
所以我覺得溝通的通道
無論你找什麼樣的管道溝通
其實那個也都是跟自己對話
蠻好的方式
對我我發現哲珮你有一個很大特色
是因為有些人在說明自己的狀態
或是在自己呈現某個狀態
而別人還是會把他的期待
或他認為正確的事情放生
放過來的時候
有些人會生氣
是有些人會覺得說那我現在就這樣啊
你為什麼要這樣
之類的然後說我你跟我這麼親近
你應該要體諒我
對
所以在這個生氣的過程中又會想說
為什麼
我沒有辦法按照他的方式去做
也就是說
那個界限的模糊是
反而是讓很多人在這個瞬間
是很辛苦的
對因為我會生氣
就是因為某方面來說我不認為啊
他因為如果是像哲珮你對
你就看起來比較不會生氣
我會你也會
哈哈哈我也會
我以為你就是那種你講你的
我做我的
哈哈哈
就是因為如果比較不生氣的人
其實很簡單
就是你說你的
嗯
你要求你的
我不認為我需要按照你的方式去做
就是那個自我的意志是很強大
可是我們有時候會生氣
是因為我一方面覺得你
我希望你體諒我
另外一方面我心裡有個
小聲音在想說
我是不是應該像他講的那樣做
我怎麼沒有做到他講的那樣
然後心裡默默懊惱
對那個感覺所以你也是這種感覺嗎
啊應該說我覺得
內在你當然會覺得
呃我我沒有覺得你講的錯
可是你可不可以換一種方式說
沒錯沒錯
其實主要都是因為
我就說我是一個講情緒的人
有的時候
我讀到的不是你講的話
而是你這個話後面的情緒的情緒
那我也知道
我不應該把自己鎖在那個情緒
可是我覺得
那就是有一種靈魂天生的設定
所以有的時候我也會告訴我自己
察覺就是這個是情緒還是這個情緒
跟我有關係嗎
還是其實跟我無關
我正在一直在練習這件事情
很讚欸
對但是就是過程中你會
你會感覺就是我不是
不要停可是可不可以換一個方式
那對方可能會著急覺得
可是我現在沒有辦法顧及你的情緒
因為每個人有自己的靈魂的設定嘛
對那在這過程中
我覺得他其實都是要時間
我覺得有時候爭吵也沒有不好
他就是一個溝通的管道
因為我有爭吵的時候
有的時候你才會把心裡話說出來
對對那只是我覺得那是我們夠不夠
呃負責任或夠不夠成熟
就是你要知道你說的話
你不是我故意要傷害你的
或是你會不會說出讓自己後悔的話
那這件事情是我覺得我從小就知道的
就是我從來從小到大
從來沒有在吵架的時候說我們分手
我從來沒有講過這句話
但是我知道很多
人吵架的時候可能會講這句話
但因為我知道那句話的重量
所以無論如何
我會知道有些底線在哪裡
可是我還是可以發洩我的情緒
那所謂的情緒是
我只是想要表達我的感覺
被你誤會的部分是什麼
對
前額葉長得非常好的
哈哈哈
哈哈哈情緒控制的方面
對我就想說
哇塞你居然
從來沒有在吵架的時候講過分手
就連我都講過啊
就年輕的時候都講過
這太了不起了
所以哲珮
我最後還是想要回到就是你的專輯
因為我印象最深刻的幾首歌
就是剛剛說的《與世隔絕的怪物》
《黑洞》還有《樹洞裡可以悲傷》
我不知道在這幾首歌裡面
或是甚至其他首歌
你有沒有特別想要拿出來跟大家分享
就是寫那一首歌對你來說
你想要傳達的
還有他對你的重要性啊
或是呃
你在寫這首歌的一些情境等等
好
因為你剛剛提到這幾首歌
我覺得很有趣
他剛好是排在我的曲序的連續
這樣子《與世隔絕的怪物》《黑洞》
《樹洞裡可以悲傷》
他的確是一個
我墜落到重生的一個縮影
應該怎麼說
因為我專輯如果分成上下半場的話
這也是上半場的歌
那其實我專輯在創作的時候
最早之前
我的主題本來是與世隔絕的怪物
因為當時我的狀態還在那裡
我還在黑洞
所以我以為我要做一張
都是這麼冷掉的東西
那冷掉的東西
我知道我會做
所以我以為我要做這個
那直到我寫出黑洞的時候
你看我在前面寫的
時候我也以為我是要墜落的
可是其實對於創作者來講
其實創作就是一個
你通往潛意識的通道
我的確是讓創作跟我的聲音跟著我
所以我沒有設定
我不知道我這首歌最後會變成什麼樣
可是寫著寫著我才發現
原來我是不想消失的
原來我還是想看見光的
所以當我寫完這首歌的時候
我才理解我其實是想要從黑洞出來了
我覺得可以了
然後這首歌把我接住了
當你沒有辦法說明你的感受
沒有人瞭解你的時候
我覺得這首歌接住我了
然後在這首歌接住我之後的下一步
我在想著
天吶身為創作者
我們常常為別人寫歌
寫歌給情人
寫歌給家人朋友
甚至幫很多歌手寫歌
可是我突然想
從來都沒有人為我寫歌過
甚至我自己都沒有
不是寫歌給我自己唱
是有什麼話對我自己說
所以我就想著
那我要寫一首歌給我自己
那當下
我最想聽到我自己跟我說什麼
我可不可以讓一個比較有力量的我
跟我說話
所以樹洞裡可以悲傷
第一句話才會是失去方向
就躲回樹洞吧
沒有關係
我在這裡
我覺得是這個念頭帶著我寫了這首歌
然後我也覺得
我真的找到了我心裡面的樹洞
好贊哦那我就可以懂了
因為我那時候在聽與世隔絕的怪物
我很喜歡對不對
因為我覺得應該就是
因為我們做金屬的樂風就是很
然後到黑洞的時候我覺得很有趣
因為你前面一直大轉小
大轉小大調轉小調
大調轉小調
然後後面就大調了
然後那個大調之後那個明亮感很強
然後接到樹洞裡可以悲傷
就感覺非常的一氣呵成
然後所以我剛剛就在想
你在寫這些歌的時候
是不是有一些你自己的心路歷程
那你自自己這樣說明就完全懂
為什麼會有這樣子的
但是那些一切都不是我設計的
就是我在寫
前面樹洞也是很抒情
我也沒有想到我副歌會飛起來
對所以我才發現我的力量還在的
是所以我從我的創作中去理解
我自己的力量還在
所以在這個過程中
我真的我也蠻慶幸
我是用音樂在把自己撐起來的
好棒對
好棒所以
因為其實關於樹洞裡可以悲傷
這張專輯
已經有非常多朋友去聽了之後
都覺得很療癒
那我想我也不用再多推薦什麼
但是真的是一張
我覺得很
就是在你很覺得你很困難
跟很不容易的時刻
我覺得這是一張可以陪伴你的專輯
對所以很歡迎
大家可以好好支持哲珮的這一張專輯
謝謝 《樹洞裡可以悲傷》
那最後我想請哲珮可以給
例如說和你一樣曾經經歷過
例如說掉進黑洞裡的朋友
然後在悲傷裡
可能不那麼容易走的出來
或是發現現在面對一個困境
好像伸手不見五指
如果想要給他們一點點
就是回應或是鼓勵的話
你想要跟他們說什麼
就像我歌說的
就是我的歌詞裡面說就是沒有關係
真的沒有關係
你只要知道
你自己還是有某些責任的啊
我們還是別人的小孩
所以不要
做出讓家人會傷心難過的事情
你只要自己知道你的責任在哪裡
其實你不用急著好起來
因為每一個悲傷的過程
它都是你必須要經歷它
你才有可能變成另外一個自己
所以我覺得
他真的有時候很像是靈魂的換氣期
就像如果我不是經歷了這一輪黑洞
我覺得我會做出一張這樣的專輯
那張專輯
如果可以療癒到更多更多的人
那我覺得我可以理解
這是宇宙需要我經歷這麼一次
讓我自己經歷之後
然後產出了一些我自己覺得療癒
我自己的音樂
也希望這個療癒能量是很具體的
可以把聲音上面療癒
也傳達給跟我一樣
曾經經歷或者正在經歷黑洞的人
我相信一定可以的
真的很棒
這一次謝謝哲珮
推出速凍裡可以悲傷這張專輯
我想可以陪伴很多很多
在不容易時刻的朋友
那也今天很謝謝哲珮接受我們的訪問
謝謝 那麼周慕姿放心說
我們下次見嘍
掰掰